hello um welcome to the tourist district
council's meeting of external overview
and scrutiny committee wednesday the 1st
of june
um this is quite strange for me i've
been vice chair for quite a few years
but i've never actually had to chair a
meeting
so bear with me
um
[Music]
agenda item one apologies for absence
i've had apologies from councillor
wiseman
and we've had apologies from kenton
baker councillor manly
councillor woodhouse and stacey
okay thank you
and go through the minutes of the last
meeting
page
okay page numbers at the top page one
page two
page three
[Music]
page four
five
six
seven
eight hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
have you got any public participation
not today
[Music]
which has already been approved by the
budget but we still need to have the
report come to external
that's right
[Music]
[Music]
met with uh chair of midterm and
scrutiny committee
just before the last meeting
i think that we'll go on a forward plan
i'm sorry yeah as far as i understand it
chair and
counselor man you might have another
meeting with devon just to clarify where
who's involved bring her to orange
perspective
okay
so that's
sort of ongoing
um 137
i think we all received the emails
through from karen in answer of the
questions and the questions that we have
to the environment agency
thank you
and the next one the answer's from
southwest water it says complete but
actually we didn't receive all the
answers because i've spoken with
councillor harding and um
about the concerns of the raw sewage at
bucks mills
give you something basically i've got a
little update mark beer from morocco
which has um got out of us and uh said
that that despite his earlier um
pessimism uh he can confirm that
southwest water just announced the to
have accepted in principle the first
time sewerage scheme of um
uh bucks bills um there's a few details
uh um that they um
time-wise say they they have no
information but however the project
needs to be placed within five years due
to the
statute anyway and
basically they they've got to give us a
lot more information
and
but it is going to be doing they're
going to um adopt the uh old sewage um
which has never been used um down
through which
um got
i think in 1978 79 something like that
so uh you know so things move slowly in
our neck of the woods but it looks like
it is moving so that's good but they're
still yet to
to to tell us exactly what they're going
to do so i was wondering if that's a
committee we could contact them again
with confirmation of what's actually
happening to try and push that forward
this would be good some clarity would be
good do we need to focus on that just
make it an action point put it down
there's another action yeah yeah
it sounds like positive
[Music]
[Music]
declarations of interest members with
interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is considered
agreement of agenda items part one and
two there's no part two items
are there any urgent matters brought to
bring forward
in the commission of the chair i haven't
received any no
so now
natural devon an opportunity to hear
from harry barton regarding the progress
of nature recovery network
thank you and welcome
it's nice to have someone here in person
rather than
through a screen well thank you very
much for inviting me so um
so yes i'm going to talk about
progressing the nature recovery network
map the toolkit and yes i'm chief
executive wildlife trust and uh the
nature recovery network uh is really a
concept that's not owned by the wildlife
trust at all i'd like to think so about
the whole county
it's moral ownership if you like is the
local nature partnership
and um the accountable body is the devil
catch council
and we're the grants we try and make it
happen
so if you have the next slide please um
we've got as i think we all know uh
amazing wildlife here in devon we're
very very lucky particularly from but
compared to parts of the world where i
was brought up when you lived for 12
years or so
and these include uh the large open
areas and bogs on areas like dartmoor
and the heath on export of course these
wonderful
flooded
in devon river
cornwall um this one's just around the
corner from where i live now uh
something unique really to southwest
england next slide please
um and just as as good as the stuff we
have on land is the stuff we've got out
at sea in fact at least half our
wildlife here in the southwest region is
out it's seen so we've got these
wonderful reefs
these kelp beds these um seal grass
vents etc most of us don't get to see
that most of the time sitting beneath
the waves but we do quite often
if we're standing on the coast of the
right place at the right time see
something where the stacks actually like
this like dolphins and of course the
dolphins would not be there if it wasn't
for all this invisible stuff next like
this
um but we know we've lost an awful lot
and they chose a lot of trouble we know
that we've got an ecological crisis and
there are a few reasons for this this is
the first reason um
we've lost an awful lot of that natural
habitat so there's a habitat called
chrome grassland which i'm sure we're
well aware of it was
i wouldn't say it's unique but it's
highly unusual outside uh north west
seven and northeast cornwall few minutes
and elsewhere
and you can see here in this slide
on the left-hand picture this sort of
very sort of scatter
approach of tiny little dots around it
now covers about one and a half percent
of the landscape you look at
to 1947 you're looking at 30 to 40
percent of the landscape cover so that's
a huge reduction
uh next cycles
and a lot of the remaining bits are very
isolated now having said congrats this
actually is called grass
so this is this is a different type of
habitat but it's it's it's in this area
this was you're looking at one of our
smallest nature reserves it's about five
acres in size it used to cover this type
of habitat the whole of what's on that
slide there and beyond but you can see
agriculture build development et cetera
has eaten into it
now we do our best to look after the
status there it's a lovely place but
every decade we record less and less
wildlife on it and the reason is that
because it's so small every population
is very small so one hard winter one bad
drought population is wiped out and
there's nowhere from the surrounds for
it to come back in
so there's a problem uh with with trying
to conserve wildlife and lots and lots
of those tiny little sites that you saw
on the previous slide next one please
we also have an issue with the condition
of habitat now i spend a lot of my time
on dartmouth i love running on dartmouth
my heart rather sings when i come across
a landscape like this because you can't
try and run through it
but it is amazing for wildlife and it's
even more important for carbon and water
supplies because of course this is just
like a giant sponge and although the
sponge is made up of this
tens of thousands of
years of accumulation of heat and when
it's in good condition you get these
wonderful things the battle world the
sun view etc on it but next slide please
most of that habitat is now starting to
look like this
so dry summer's uh erosion around the
edge of these so it drains it off and it
dries out and that peat starts to
oxidize and so sadly most of the rocks
on dartmoor now are sources of carbon
rather than sinks of color and you'll
probably notice the grass around it is
looking about the dial as well and
that's because as it's dried out it
doesn't support all that wide range of
species it once did
that looks like it
and what really upsets me is that we're
still losing stuff we're doing much
better job than we used to conservatives
but we're still losing stuff now this is
a very good quality couple of slides you
can imagine it's not easy getting
pictures like this but this is this is
two days apart
and this is a marine habitat and on the
left you see something that's all right
it's not from a david attenborough film
in in the coral reef in the tropics but
it's quite a healthy bit of seafloor
habitat and on the right this is what's
happened when it's been bottom dredged
and that it takes away of course the
habits happen it does something else as
well it stirs up all that all those
sediments in the sea floor and all that
carbon this is an incredibly important
source of carbon that doesn't get talked
about much that all will bubble up into
the water column and eventually fly this
way into the atmosphere so it's a big
problem with the climate as well as uh
as the sea floor habitat and the fish
that feed on it next slide please
so um things need to change we all know
that and we've had some very important
policy drivers in the last few years so
here's the first one the 25 year plan to
improve the environment which came out a
few years ago
followed quite uh closely uh by the
environment act and now of course you've
got a great paper on environment targets
and this is driving uh several things
that one of the things that was in there
was this mention of the nature recovery
network the nature recovery network
really is just is this idea of more
habitats bigger areas better connected
up and better condition
and it's very much a concept
next likelihood
um but like all these concept you need
to have some high level ambition and
what the scientists tell us we need is
30 percent of land in scene allowed and
see rather in recovery for wildlife now
i say recovery because you can't just
wave your magic bond and create an
ancient woodland it takes quite a lot of
decades or even centuries sometimes so
this is about getting everything in the
right direction but that 30 percent is a
key figure for us and devon rather
alarmingly means pretty much doubling
the amount of land that we have in
wildlife compared to what we've got
about much more than that in some other
parts of the country next slide please
now um first bit of controversy is how
do you interpret that 30 percent because
it is absolutely critical we've got to
know what we're trying to wait for
now deference original i'll say original
because it's slightly changing it's
tuned up its original interpretation of
this was that the third anything that is
protected by where we got a landscape
designation would cut towards the
settings so all of dartmouth would count
all about small account all of north
dominion would be encountered
and you see the trouble with that
interpretation straight away so this is
exmoor i love this part of exports just
around the corner from where my parents
got married
and
see looking across this beautiful
landscape but of course you can see most
of that is pretty low it is actually
quite intensively found it's not
actually land for nature some of it is
but not all of it
so the real picture um is
you know it is
means that we've got a much higher
target to reach than that
next slide please
so this is where the game plan comes in
the nature recovery network map that
we've been drive driving forward at the
wildlife trust
and the first stage is to work out what
we've already got and you'll think would
you not that after all these years we'd
know exactly what we've got in devon
and i'm afraid you'll be wrong um
because we have lots and lots of data
but there are all different data sets
they're all different ages they're all
stored in different ways they're all
incomplete they're not all compatible so
it took us a good year of work just to
get to come up with a consistent picture
of what we've actually got and there are
lots and lots of ways to show that no
one map can show you all the um the
wildlife habitats you've got because
it'll just be a horrible mess but this
is the sort of thing you can get
as a result of it so but that's that in
itself is a big step forward and you can
see this picture of you know very very
scattered little bits here and there
that's like this
now more excitingly um
is looking at what the landscape of
devon could actually be in the future
and again this is complicated because
uh the other there's no one answer to
that you can take a field out there and
what could it be it depends what you do
if you graze it lightly it might turn
into some sort of scrubby open area
mixed habitat if you completely leave it
alone it will eventually turn into one
sort of woodland
or other
so we've actually looked at this in two
different ways we said bearing in mind
that most of them will turn into some
form of woodland except perhaps the very
highest bits of the dark or
flooded valleys
um
we the first the first of them to say is
what sort of woodland would this turn
into
and then the second which is what's
shown here is is what other type of
habitat if we managed a bit would it
turn into so you could look for every
bit of of devon's land you could come up
with at least two answers to what that
habitat could be
so there we are cover the hook down
and this is very broad brush of course
you can go into a much much finer
scale if we want to
next slide please
but of course we're not trying to turn
the whole of devon into one giant nature
reserve we'll have land to grow food
we'll have land to build houses etcetera
so we've gotta
we gotta refine this down a little bit
and say where are are we gonna try and
do this
and there are a number of ways we can do
that this is one this is some work we
did a few years ago actually identifying
what we called strategic major areas so
these were areas where the land perhaps
wasn't the greatest value for farmland
um and there was lots of bits of habitat
already quite close together so you
wouldn't need to do so much work to link
them all up together
so that's one possible filter you can
put over it next slide
what's the difference between the blue
and the brain
now you're asking me
they are they are
um they're there to indicate uh clusters
of habitat with a particular type of
habitat dominating okay so um the the um
the green one which covers starboard
isn't just all aptly heat but and heath
would be the dominant habitat
and the same the the green sorry the the
um
the blue in the top left uh is
cool grass and dominated and the brown
would be woodland dominated
okay
okay
so you can bring it down the level so
this is looking at uh uh tour bay i'm
sorry about photography this is
somewhere recently on tour bay and what
this is doing is saying okay again at a
fairly broad brush level but a little
bit uh fine scale um what sort of
habitats can we create so um the yellow
this is valleys that could wear which
would be good opportunities for
restoring wood steep sided valleys not
great um for modern farming um and
already quite a bit of woodland there so
great opportunities in those yellow
areas uh the the um the purple areas
that steep-sided uh um
coastal habitat great opportunity for
restoring there and the brown areas they
are other probably mixed habitat areas
where you might want to create a lot of
open open um habitats as well for local
people and brixton and painting to enjoy
so that would be a mixed habitat area so
it's still quite raw for us
next slide please
you can take it down in a fine level too
now this is exeter we call this the
extra biodiversity reference map so here
every single bit of open space in exeter
has been mapped we might want to turn it
to woodland
or open grassland or scrub or wetland or
something else
easier to do that in the urban area to
be honest because most of it's built on
so yeah and most of the rest of it is
unlikely to be found so it's a it's a
little bit easier to do it there and the
next time please and we can do this also
um and i have been doing this in the in
the more rural areas now this lashes
stretches is a fictitious farm
uh but it shows the sort of thing you
can do so you can take this right down
to field by field basis and say uh this
we would leave alone but this is not a
particularly productive area of land um
it would be a great opportunity to
return this to congrats and or woodland
or wetland or something else so it's
very very useful decision making support
to a strategic level if but also to very
much an individual and the average level
next slide please
now
i've been talking very much about nature
so far but there's more than one agenda
at play here you probably heard this
latest buzzword nature-based solutions
which basically means anything that
nature can do to help the society or
economic probability of health um water
or anything else
but what i wanted to
focus on particularly here
was the role of nature in flood
alleviation and carbon sequestration
and some work that's been done by a
number of scientists suggests that uh
over a third this is 37 which i think is
quite optimistic but let's say about a
third quarter and third of all our
emissions could be dealt with um in
other words
sucked out of sequestered sucked out of
the atmosphere by nature if we look
after it properly so if you look at the
next slide please
um
on the left you see some work that we
are doing at the moment please don't
take this literally at all this is a
highly pixelated low resolution um image
here but when we finish this work we
should be able to say every single bit
of devon what is the potential for that
land for sequestering carbon
and on the right we should be able to do
exactly the same in terms of natural
flood management both of these things
important policy drivers huge amounts of
money throughout this so if we
so if we can throw all these layers of
data together we can just we can say you
know a number of things first of all
where's the best opportunity for a store
in wildlife
secondly where we get the best bangers
for bats in terms of carbon
sequestration flood alleviation and any
number of other agendas and obviously we
have to do that because aid there isn't
enough land to get around and b there
isn't enough money to do everything you
want to everywhere
so these are things that hope the
elements that we hope will be finished
within the next year
next slide please
and we are also this might take a little
longer we're doing the same in the
marine now the marine environment is a
lot more problematic as you know it's we
know much less about it it's very
mobile um a lot of things out there they
change quite regularly you don't have
boundaries of land in the same way that
we do
uh sort of boundaries in the center that
we do on land
but we think it's equally important
because it's so critical for in terms of
a carbon saw and so critical in terms of
fish stocks and and our wildlife so this
is the kind of thing we'll be working on
on in the next two years and again
there's lots of data sources this one
the one on the left here shows broad
habitat types the one on the right shows
fishing pressure so there's lots of
different you know there's pollution
data all sorts of things we could layer
on top to see where we could get again
the best thanks to bucks for doing this
scene next slide please
that's an obvious question with this
going back to land which is can we
really do all this and feed ourselves
because we've got a big problem not just
in britain but in the whole western
world
if you actually look at the demands we
place on our land uh for food the timber
for living space
you know for nature for housing
development
we probably need two and a half uk's
to do all the things we want in fact
some people argue that the population of
london alone requires the land area the
size of the uk to feed it and meet all
its needs which is pretty alive and this
is one of the reasons why we keep seeing
habitat and stuff being destroyed in
places like the amazon so we've got a
big problem as not just in the uk but as
a world order to sort this out
so if you look at the next slide please
um i think there are a number of things
we could do one is that we have to be
much more scientific about how we do
things so we say for instance
we can we can plant trees on a bit of
land or we can let's go back to nature
[ __ ] and what's the quest to come
that's not good enough it depends what
the starting point is it depends what
the end point is so this is some work
some colleagues
of mine did and you'll see that if
you're looking at drained arable lads so
however what that which sort of pigment
which was was people that was drained
and used for horrible land haven't
really got much of that in devon but
they've got heaps of that up and said
cambridgeshire and lincolnshire
if you re-wet that you get enormous
benefits in terms of carbon
sequestration
um but if you slightly change the way
you
manage your farmland you will get some
benefits but they're much much more
modest and planting trees somewhere in
the middle so
it's not just about restoring nature
it's about exactly how you're restoring
it and exactly where you'll destroy
nature so this should help us pinpoint
things much more and be much more
efficient about how we do things the
next slide
rather more controversially is how we
use our lab
now this is i don't have the answer to
this i don't think anyone really
but if you've looked at the national
food strategy of henry
this is the first report the only report
i know that's really wrestled with the
subject of how do we use our land more
effectively and what do we argue is the
agreement will disagree but he argues
that actually we do have enough land if
we use things differently we argue for
putting a third of our land in
high-yield farmland the big fields of
wheat etc um a third of our land roughly
very simplistic of course is low yield
farmer that's the sort of extensive
livestock farmer you might have on the
edge of exportable and the third in
semi-natural land effectively for nature
and he says there are three things you
need to do if we're going to do that one
easiest we've got to cut down on food
waste because a third of our waste goes
within food rather than the wind second
and secondly is we've got to dry some
volume production indoors
a bit controversial but actually you
look around there it's already happening
uh more of this stuff is now growing
glass houses and things
and thirdly and most controversially
here in devon uh he argues that we need
to reduce our meat consumption quite
significantly now whenever i say this i
i see the looks of disapproval but
actually i think what liberty is talking
about here is not so much the kind of
extensive livestock we tend to see a lot
of endeavor but these very very
intensive livestock units you've seen in
some parts of the uk but in other parts
of the world as well and producing i
have to say quite low quality meat so
it's not as scary as it sounds um but we
are going to have to wrestle with this
because whenever i talk to say
farmers groups or others about restoring
our inflammation they say well how about
that for food production so we we are
going to have to to find a way around
this
next slide please
so anyway nature recovery network it's
all in development it's at the moment
it's it's on the uh the county council
of the county council environment via
website the front page looks like this
so all these elements are being updated
constantly and hopefully month by month
the data will get better and
more clever et cetera and if someone
comes and talks to you 12 months time it
would be far more z than what i say
and and final side uh i sometimes get
asked uh you know what would it look
like if a nature recovery network was
actually put in place on the ground this
isn't my work at all this was export
national park authorities work um a
figment of the imagination of course a
bit of artists were but it's you know
it's interesting to see what the
landscape might look like and i think
the artists here
um took the view that it was an
landscape it's a national park they
didn't want to lose all the features of
the current landscape you see obviously
there's room for farming another land
used to stay but you would see a sort of
softening
of the edges and taking the foot off the
pedal that you like in terms of human uh
influence on the land
so there we are i'm done thank you
thank you thanks very much
if you've got any questions
well basically i i'm
involved with farming my son's got a
farm i used to farm and um
we
we uh farmed
a bit of land which was full of foot
cone grass and we have wet bread my
father when he was in the seventh in the
1970s he drained acres of it and i think
one of the peat
bogs went down about six foot
uh yeah so i mean there's so much water
in that in there i mean it's lush
now grassland but you know i've always
said that you know we need to work with
nature rather work against it and uh and
basically
farms
have to uh you know feed and uh and and
make it and make a living that's it oh
you've got that natural
um
patchwork so how can you kind of
compensate the farmers with subsidies
and incentives how do you do that and
also um you know i've noticed that
there's always these little blocks where
somebody does a nice good thing and then
it's all of a sudden there's nothing and
you need to make these wildlife
corridors because
it's like the badger if the badgers uh
gets too many he he has a big fight with
all these neighbors and then they they
they go and and and the young get pushed
and then you know then they reset
somewhere else and and this is why the
five acre is not enough because you know
it kind of there always a a yin and yang
going on and uh so you you need those
peripheral ends so wildlife corridor
which seems to be the best idea so
surely there needs to be more of a
joined up thinking
with farmers yeah i mean loads of points
that you made there are all really good
ones i mean first of all
yeah i mean for decades farmers were
paid to drain these things and fire them
up and take other hedges and stuff um
and sometimes it made agricultural sense
sometimes it didn't i think there's an
opportunity now with elves although
elvis has been a little bit
disappointing so far let's face it but i
think there's an opportunity
um to uh to drive things a different way
and compensate farmers properly now
personally i've i've written to other
all my local bees about this and
lobbying nationally i think
the sustainable farm incentive which is
largely seen i think is the replacement
for basic payment scheme isn't there a
way for it for purpose i don't think
it's clearly what it's trying to do i
don't think the payment levels are high
enough uh there's no sense of ambition
there and the things like um if you
monitor your soil but why you gotta have
a reason for doing these things so i
think it needs a real rethink and it is
disappointing that it sort of lost its
original
um sense of ambition but i think it's
not too late to save it but i don't i do
think the new subsidy regime really has
to build some of the stuff in i also
think you know there's things that make
sense a strategic level and things that
make sense at an individual farm level
so an individual farm level we have 25
odd farm advice wildlife trusts and you
know most farmers
exactly like you you know their main
business is producing food that's why
they're farmers but they're always
corners of the farm where they like to
do other stuff as well
and what we can do with the model like
this to say was where actually you get
the best bangs for bucks because
maybe this is something that you
obviously use the farm you know this
anyway but there might be steep slopes
which are being plowed and
why you might actually putting more
energy to that than getting food out of
it so why why don't we let that go into
a habitat that will actually help um
slow the flow of water
and sequester some carbon on the side
etcetera and get some wildlife benefits
too so we can always do that in an
individual farm level and it's easier to
do if you get some decent incentives
through through the subsidy scheme but
then i think in a more strategic level
we need to be able to answer your five
acre question which is you know these
things on their own it's nice to have
them but
how much they actually deliver so there
where i think we can say well there
needs to be areas where the scheme can
say okay we're going to try and
prioritize maybe get a bit more money
maybe make it a little bit easier in
these particular zones to do this kind
of thing
and and then hopefully you'll get even
if you do get individual five acre
patches they'll be much more closely
connected to each other we can perhaps
build the hedge networks and other
corridors which don't take too much um
you know productive farmer underway to
get them all back together again so
there's well i think we've got the
potential to do all this it's just the
schemes the funding aren't quite quite
ready yet well i listened yesterday of
interest to uh professor peter smith
who's a soil scientist and he was saying
that sometimes it's not the right idea
to plant trees because you've got
grassland and that's holding them in
carbon it's a it's more of a
parkland and it is a a permanent pasture
but the silliest thing in the world is
the planet to dig that up and put trees
because by the time they get to the uh
state they need to that grass would that
grassland would have held in the carbon
so how much of science do you use you
know for that because you know obviously
you know you're advising farmers to do
that so you've got to look at all the
which we try to be as science-led as
possible so we generally my general
feeling is if you want to plant trees
uh it's a good idea to do it on the most
excuse me knackered land possible that's
the best way to do it if it's already a
decent habitat don't plant trees on it
because you know even if you're creating
something good you'll be losing
something good so what's the point of
doing that um
there's enough land we can
quadruple easily the amount of trees
you've got in there and not touch some
of the best habitat we've got so there's
absolutely no reason for doing that um
there are some well uh publicized
examples like the best one is what
happened in the 80s when there was a tax
break for plums and conifers in the flow
country which was
bad for all sorts of reasons um but it
still has i think it's happening less
now than much less than it was but it is
still an issue but science is absolutely
key to all of this i think the more we
have to be really data driven um because
it's all about fine-tuning that we don't
there's isn't enough room for
flexibility anymore we've left it too
late we've got too much to do
thank you but thank you
yep um
thank you chad um have you mentioned at
the beginning of your presentation about
the loss of the
calm glass habitats and now is that
through climate change or development
well
it's i'm pleased to say quite a lot of
them it started to be put back which is
which is great but the original loss is
actually quite recent so compared to say
ancient woodland and maine and jamaica
sports medics which are lost principally
in the 50s and 60s 40s and 60s the cool
grassland was mainly lost in the 1890s
and
a mixture of things some of it
has been drained and improved
[Laughter]
and you don't fancy that uh some of it
has been a lot of it actually was
planted with conifers
um on that again incentivized schemes
not obviously very well
very well directed but that happened a
lot of it some of it uh was
neglected which isn't necessarily bad in
the end because you can get some quite
nice wood but you do obviously you gain
one habitat but lose another so you
don't get any overall gain there so
those are the three main reasons for it
um and uh interestingly going back to
the point just making before where we've
been quite successful in reintroducing
it is actually land that is almost
always of marginal value to the thumb or
anyway because you need to work so hard
to keep it dry um to keep you know to
stop the nutrients or running away so
when you actually think about all that
all the chemicals all the energy you're
pumping into the land it's actually
better sometimes just to leave it and
let it reverse to what it would
naturally be and then you still get
benefits of it they're not food benefits
so much but their benefits in terms of
storing carbon purifying water reducing
flooding
thank you thank you so much that was
fascinating and i think i understood
most of it
that's brilliant that slide is so useful
to have a picture
of what it might look like and you can
really see what would be wildlife
corridors and everything what i
specifically wanted to ask was you know
you were talking about the moor and the
fact that the parts of it now are
give producing carbon and i think
can that be salvaged or is that because
of climate change and it i can salvage i
mean it's it's not easy because
obviously we turn about every year's
difference in it but um we tend to have
on average longer and drier stands now
um
and uh some of the things that have
happened in dartmoor are centuries old
so uh dan wasn't sure you know where it
was a heavily industrialized area of
victorian times there are rail lines all
over the place
one of the areas i like to run on is
called red lake and actually you look
around you see this huge great sort of
it's like a sort of
the entire stands type development would
have probably been at the time and
so what you're actually seeing is a
healed industrial scar over a lot of
dartmouth it might take several hundred
years for all that to come back but
there are some things can be done and i
think when i think particularly in those
in those um
raised bogs which is when you get a sort
of lens
on the top of the hills um they're
particularly prone to erosion because
you can imagine as as
if it's in a valley then the water sits
in the valley but it's on the top of the
hill it's easy for the edges to start
eroding and then all the water pours
down the hillside and the way to restore
that it's quite intensive i have to say
quite expensive but they basically just
plug the areas where you get the most of
that erosion going on the gully erosion
that just keeps the water in place and
so that can be done um the
i think
there are areas where um
land has been just badly managed so i
think probably burned too much in the
past not so much it's present well
that's what's happened in the past so so
some areas that have been burned over
and over and over um and i think that is
the case for saying okay if we can it's
obviously what's difficult in there and
we can't write um the common growth but
we can say we're just been today perhaps
for a decade let the landscape heal a
little bit and then it can start taking
a bit more
and then another thing we'll do is is
trying to protect the vaginas which is
that now they're on the edge of dark
and
um
particularly well-known one i just you
might have heard of ends where you get
pictures of the whole thing covered in
bluebells that's one of our nature
reserves and that's one of the bad
advice but they're not protected at all
so a lot of them are
still being halted a lot of the time and
they're really not very large areas i
don't think there's much to be gaining
agriculturally from uh for trying to
improve it so we're just suggesting
protector because they are so good but
they actually heal much more quickly
because they're not so high else dude
things really that mean when growing
conditions are a bit better they'll
recover a lot more quickly
and actually
they've reached as well and the ones on
the top of the very top of the hills
thank you thank you
council laws uh yes
i'd be interested to know
how closely you work with districts and
county and government
on planet
um because we get a requirement
[Music]
in a strip
backing onto the a b
just within the last week
animals have been cut off and living
within that narrow strip and we're
actually getting deer
coming down to west virginia
it just concerns me that you're working
as hard as you can
i do not see
thousands of people wanting to buy
houses
in westwood home
what i see is people who want to come
here and buy retirement homes
to get some structure in yeah now really
really good point and um yeah it's
always a concern isn't it you're trying
to gain one side and then you find
yourself losing ground on the other side
so we engage a lot with the whole
development industry at national level
um you're absolutely right uh the
domination of a few big companies is
problematic not just in the housing
industry it's in it it's a problem with
lots and lots of sectors but
particularly in that sector
um and so we do engage with that
i think they are a mixed bag there are
some i won't be wrong with me today
names but there are there are some
companies that i think are genuinely
wanting to change wanted to push the
agenda with eco homes and build more
green spaces around developments which
of course can be done and there are some
good not surprises or rather
impressively few of them but there are
some good examples of where you know
nature and all these things can be built
into new developments you can actually
end up with something that is better
than
what you started with but very often
that's not the case very often the
houses are not well built in fact a lot
of the houses built now in terms of
ecological standards are probably worse
than they were 15 years ago which is
very very frustrating so we are engaging
i would say with mixed success at that
national level at the local level i mean
well
we try and work with every council in
terms of uh
feeding into this local development
framework
last year actually we i think we
commented or objected to more
development proposals that we've ever
done in our history so it's that's
partly because there's so many many more
of them going on
so it keeps us extremely busy
in all honesty how effective are we i
don't know
but we will keep trying yeah sure
can i just come back one of the problems
we have is that and i'm sure it must
frustrate we've had capsule leather our
chair planning is that
when a planning application comes in it
seems to have to be looked at in
isolation
on this particular site i was talking
about
five different aspects the issue of
cumulative impact isn't it yeah
and
we could have
if allowed
it's very frustrating well actually just
last week i wrote to all um 12 mps in
devon they hear from me rather more
often than i think they'd like but
in this case i was writing them about
the um the leveling up um
and whatever it's called but you know
which is essentially about the new
planning system among other things
and this point of cumulative impact was
something i made quite strongly in that
letter uh because and you're absolutely
right you know you could eat each thing
is you know it's a strawberry bread that
comes back is that each individual straw
is not particularly significant but
taking them all together it can be very
very significant i think it's a real
weakness in the proposals that they
don't take enough account of that so yes
and they agree thank you yeah yeah if i
could i think uh it was a good point
cancer laws
but and and you're quite right there a
planning application is considered on
its own merits but that cumulative
impact should be considered a plan
making stage
so as you formulate your local plan
things should be allocated will
accumulate in impact should be looked at
at that point now the problem we've got
currently is obviously we're not plan
lead because of our current lack of
five-year housing land supply so you
have unplanned for development coming
through the system so that's why we work
with
local partners like the airb partnership
like biosphere reserve and then and you
have in place you things like your your
biodiversity net gain
that we work with them to try and get
the best out of but it is essentially
unplanned development in those instances
i must just come back and say okay so
we're working with our mp because he's
putting the government is doing too much
strain on us and we can't
we can't work within
the limits you know you
[Music]
yeah i just find it so frustrating that
you your hands are tired now but just be
not not built enough
and that just seems
ridiculously carry on
the system i mean i think a lot of us
with entirely sharing or frustration
and of course um
you know sparing or blushes but i think
like most local authorities you know you
have an awful lot of resources taken
away um you're going about 10 15 years
you've had ecological expertise
which had to be sacrificed
um and um it's not that you know the
whole system is not as efficient as it
once was and things don't get picked up
understandably because of that so
another point i've played
two mps is that needs to be addressed
you need to be resourced to your job
properly
thank you very much and a really
important discussion with planning um
because we do things in the micro we
don't see the wider situation and we've
got it together
and we've got a development out here
that um it's been a clash between
agriculture and housing and all the rest
and it's going to be an interesting
debate that's going to come out i think
at the end of the day on that one um but
what the first of all declare a personal
interest because i'm a landowner
i do receive
payments from her majesty i'm glad
you're still there to keep paying me it
was a good thing to go on i'm glad you
used to do it to keep the price of food
though but suddenly the price of food is
beginning to rise very very very
dramatically and i'm at an age that i've
now seen things go full circle
i was born and i was given a russian
book you wouldn't believe it seeing my
size but um
i wasn't and um i trained in farming uh
training agriculture
and we were trained under a white paper
called food from our own resources i
think it was a 1966 white paper from
central government
and uh it encouraged food production and
it was done then by the politicians who
served in the second world war and we
had to produce food from our own
resources we depended upon food because
obviously german action new boats et
cetera et cetera we were struggling to
survive and we were being starved rather
than blooming if you like
of the north sea and that's the way it
was going so the policies came and i can
see why we had all the drainage done and
all these lovely areas because we wanted
to grow grass and wheat and core and etc
interest in that slide you said 29
from improved and good quality peat man
because that is where the real driver
for carbon capture is if you follow
logic to it
but then um and i think um um
coach de harden mentioned about the 80s
and you mentioned about the 80s and
change and the change there was
that because we were under intensive
production all the time and we were paid
pretty well almost for anything
we kept reducing and there was aircraft
hangers full of grain and
butter mountains and wine legs and
tomato pins everywhere um there were
lorries going around europe with nothing
in them and claiming subsidies and all
the rest of it was unbelievable um and
that was
right in the middle of the 80s and they
changed the scheme from being paying for
goods for actually paying more towards
management so the production wasn't
there we went back into a just-in-time
food production situation
and it had a huge effect not on the
primary
industries but the second industry
though if you look at torrington
um i don't know if you're north carolina
at all
not that well
do you know the big creamery then at the
moment
there was a big creamy quite close
furniture which will close down
1984 nice 34
right
that was never used
there was also a meat plant at
darlington there was also a
court method at tarrington there was
also a middle martial situation at
harrington we used to work at saikon and
there's a big paper faction that was
shut down yeah and what happened in the
80s was the change in policy agriculture
policy that came into being i can see
why because it was totally stupid to
have brain motions covering her ears and
i can see why that came in that
direction but there's nothing for for
our secondary industries was that
thornton
became a a business town and it's a
business town that died and the new
businesses what replaces we have in
ports now is the elderly and we have
care homes in harrington and it's the
biggest business in torrington so it's a
time to die
to be resurrected by caring for the
dying which is quite a strange
way of saying things but it killed an
agricultural power that's dependent upon
secondary agricultural businesses
and i hear all this
and you know i do receive famous and i'm
rapping with the changes and i'm very
disillusioned with the the lms system to
the present moment because i try to
understand it i read that i can't even
start considering things until i
register with some authority who've not
even given me any carbon codes about the
land that i own if i i decide to go down
this line
i also go against the background that i
see a government who's prepared to do
deals with australia
and import based on the less
quality standard that we produce in this
country
and i wonder where we're going to go
because well i think we're going to
finish in the west
for porridge economically
and our local plan or or torres profile
is not very good at picking up
agriculture activity
but this is secondary industries again
are going to suffer here because i think
the prime industries are going to go
slow down but i don't think it's going
to replace anything by a second range
because once you plant a tree you don't
need anybody to do very much until you
harvest that three thirty years later
and i just got a word one if you've got
the melbourne woods which is one of our
woodlands a lot of people walk it's the
most uninhabited of wildlife areas you
could ever wish to imagine it's trees
yes but there's nothing in it it's just
unbelievable
a lot of
these poorly planned plantations aren't
that great i agree no i mean a lot of
really good points there i know i mean
i'm i'm
i'm in my mid-50s i remember a lot of
this myself um and i was raised on a
farm and i have i've never called myself
a farmer but i have managed a couple of
farm businesses before all those
endeavors and you know it's it's really
really difficult i agree it's really
difficult um i think the current system
is a mess i would entirely agree it's
deeply frustrating we don't claim
payments um for
you know kind of basic payment scheme
but we had claimed things like
stewardship and then had to pay it back
further loaded it back for some
completely serious reason
you know it drives you absolutely insane
but it saves a real opportunity to sort
sorted out and i think elves so far i
hope it changes but so far i think it's
a missed opportunity because it just
doesn't have there's a high level
rhetoric and then there's what's
actually happening it's a big gap
um in terms of uh you know the the stuff
the the post-war mentality of god
reduced food really good reason for that
and we absolutely don't want to slip
back into where we were before and not
be
properly self-sufficient in food um the
nature agenda and carbon general
incredibly important too i think i don't
see those two as so uh mutually
exclusive as some people do it's
difficult but you can't find ways of
bringing them together but i think if
you're going to bring them together
you've got to sort out the best which is
the subsidy right here so can i just
then continue to follow on from chair
with your permission yeah yeah um what i
mean full circle
is that um part of our income comes from
payments from the government still we're
still in the old systems okay
and now they're suddenly this year only
a month ago brought forward our payments
early because they want us to put
fertilizer on the ground again to grow
more wheat
and i'm suddenly seeing decisions made
as i saw as a child and when i was
training in agriculture to increase our
food production again which is almost
country so when i started seeing it full
circle i've come from
post-second world war
to wanting less agriculture to all of a
sudden in the last two or three months
since the ukrainian situation
wanting more weak and when you see some
of the decisions made by india devout or
weak exports for instance some decisions
made by germany
we seem to be behind the curb a bit but
all of a sudden the last four or five
weeks we received stuff going through
the post the government want us to do
some more food again and i i just find
how do you find that
when you're doing it and that's what i
mean when we're going full circle
because we're going back
into post-second
i think there's obviously there's a
there's a crisis which we hope will be
short-term
uh maybe not that short term but it's
you know hopefully won't last for too
long
um i think it's always dangerous to make
long-term policy on the basis of the
short-term situation personally
um but i think there are things a lot of
things that the government could do to
alleviate the food crisis we've got
which they're currently not doing i'd
love to see
um
i think the single
single
easiest thing they could do which
wouldn't necessarily solve everyone's
problems overnight but i think it's just
to make the schemes they got much much
clearer
because i think as farmers you need to
know what direction you're going in and
and you need them once once you've
agreed with
people giving themselves to you what the
direction is they need to make it easier
for you to do your stuff
um otherwise
money gets wasted we don't achieve
anything
um and and it becomes a mess so i think
if there's one thing they could do if we
sort that out
clarity yeah i was just wondering if we
could put that into a recommendation
from this committee
um to go forward to central government
because obviously we've heard from you
and we've heard the concerns and they
are concerns that we've shared a lot
less from the farming community
hopefully
um does that need to be a proposal
i think i think clarity uh great greater
clarity in the um in the subsidy regime
is absolutely critical
[Music]
[Music]
it my proposal would be that we ask um
the defra department
environment food and rural affairs
to be
get greater clarity
um in the direction that would likely
give rural areas in the management of
land so that we're encompassing all
areas and that not just agricultural
businesses but we're actually asking for
clarity
of how we manage the land resource that
we have yeah load seconds that is
everyone happy to
[Music]
the money but then the policy is the
kind of direction
the regulations go around
shall we write to jeffrey cox and the
secretary of state for death
yes good idea yeah yeah
and
yeah
so recognizing that
obviously should write the new parish
because he did the champion
champion
he knows a little bit
so the main issue is our concern over
the environmental land management scheme
we recognize that there's an opportunity
but it's nothing
it's not being acted on and we need more
clarity
i can't think of
yeah because i've spoken to different
farmers and
they
well they've basically said they're not
going to bother with the elms because it
doesn't make any sense to their
commercial business um so it is a great
opportunity and it needs to be
acted on right now otherwise it's going
to be messed up
[Music]
what surprises me this afternoon is
this
nature partnership their mp was actually
established 10 years ago
it's the first time i've heard little
torridge
and i see from the letter that went
around
that um terry's district council
suggested
they would like to pledge towards this
work early this in the year so i know
you're looking for funds
i've seen the councils that are involved
and i just wonder what kind of funding
you're looking for from the district
oh right okay so so i think the um
okay well the local nature of the
opening partnership was yes that first
came in the in the white paper in 2010 i
think just that was under a previous
political regime of 2012 anyways you're
right about 10 years ago um and it was
set out yes it has been running now for
10 years and i'm currently it's vice
chair um we obviously haven't done a
very good publicity job you haven't
heard of us which i apologize um i think
the organization looking for funding
isn't actually done wildlife trust i
think that's the county council who paid
for the cost of the ministering and
would like to show that a little bit
more we actually
don't want to just give a small amount
of money about three thousand pounds a
year to help with those costs and most
of the organizations part of it who are
part of the yeah do that
and and the local nature partnership is
i mean it's not one of these
organizations that that's gonna
revolutionize the world but it's a very
good opportunity for people from all
sectors you know the local authority
statute which is ngos like ourselves
health sectors and
community groups just just to find
common ground
and we've got quite a few things done
through it so i think it is
this is this is one one in initiatives
so i think it is worth supporting being
part of um if we can tell you more about
the lnp and find ways to get you more
involved then i'd be very pleased to
hear from you as to as to how you think
we can improve
yeah
we already contribute counselling so
from planning budget we make a
contribution to county council
um to through county ecology
and to the partnership thank you thank
you on the couches
yes natural level is is the name of the
local nature departure sort of generic
name
this conversation's going between sarah
jennings and
[Music]
we started funding a couple of years ago
actually we fund each year making a
contribution i can't remember if the top
of my head is a couple of thousand
pounds or something
[Music]
so where do you see it going now
so i think our next um
the next plans for this the nature
recovery network is to work through this
carbon and those the the the water
flood alleviation connectivity to pick
up your another point you made is
another really important element to this
we had done some work on it but everyone
argued around it so we've taken it away
that connectivity is going to be really
cool and then the marine so we'll keep
building and building on the database
and then i think we just need to try and
make all the schemes out there that are
already in existence work as well as you
can for this so there's the biodiversity
net gain which obviously looks to
planning controversial but it's there we
need to try
there's the whole um carbon agenda of
the devin carbon again another way of
trying to make this work there's the
whole uh food agenda and elves exactly
we've talked about but i think there is
obviously space has been entering here
as well um and then there are other
emerging agendas as well so i think the
the nature recovery network map itself
doesn't have any statutory teeth a lot
of it did but it doesn't at the moment
but it's this decision support tool at a
strategic level at the local level um
and i guess uh when it comes back down
to the local level probably the most
powerful thing we as an organization
finding ways where they can do the
things that suit them and suit nature on
the land
because that's where you really make
things happen is working on the lab as
you were about as far
it was one of the things about actually
it's okay
um you obviously do an awful lot of work
with the protected landscape guys don't
you so did
with the northern coast
so and the lions fear so they fact they
do quite a lot on the delivery of the
planet
and we actually fund local initiatives
to contribute towards the on the ground
delivery so different projects so not
necessarily funding the strategic
elements of it as much as you might want
to but we actually fund the local
delivery of some schemes that contribute
towards delivery of the plan
and should we get back to voting on the
recommendation
um karen what have you got
but basically what i've got written
down that you want to
uh request or ask debra via a letter to
um the
entity and secretary of state of
um uh wish for clarity
in uh regarding the subsidy regime and
internal coherence is what harry said
and then
greatly greater clarity
might want to go in there as well
because it's kind of policy and subsidy
together and the two link together you
want one for reinforcing the other
i'd be happy to look it up yeah and work
together a letter and then we can add a
little bit more in there from what we
were discussing about
if the rest of the committee is happy
with that and we vote on that principle
do we have a proposal
yeah
i want to keep it non-politically
subsidy is a huge political argument
because from a food producer side it is
cheap food that the service is
protecting
not agricultural businesses and you go
into the land of politics if you put the
word subsidy in because there is two
sides to how you view a subsidy and i
would want to keep i'm going to put my
proposal and if somebody doesn't want a
second that's fine but i'll put it down
here to bring forward clear directions
in regard to future lab usage with
particular focus on the alms schemes
full stop and off
that is my recommendation
so if you can make it what you like
maybe argue from the agriculture side or
the wildlife side i think there's so
much we've got in common so i do once
beyond other sides of the pulse
we are in the same column together if
you follow logic to it but i want us
to be able to to have a common voice
because we are rural and interstate
farming and farming you know um and it's
an unbalanced balanced view in this
community and europe i think got some
connection with farming as well there
yeah i think you've told us previously
actually if i listen carefully to you so
um i i didn't want to to get into
the the agricultural versus the the
wildlife situation i just want
government to be more clear
about
those who work in and manage within the
countryside as a whole
the direction they want to take and
that's what i want to try and achieve
from the resolution i'm putting
like yeah repeat it forward please okay
to bring forward newer interventions in
regard to future land usage
with particular focus on the elms
schemes which the environmental plan
management
schemes full stop end off yeah
and we can all i would imagine you get
around that i don't know but if you want
to make it but that's what my proposal
is and i would call for a second
question can i just quit can i task
something right because i don't have the
same level of knowledge and
understanding at all as you do but would
that therefore include because i thought
from what you were saying before that
one of the issues was that the subsidy
schemes aren't clear we're not
questioning subsidies happening
there isn't enough clarity within it is
what you've said there
would that encompass
the clarity of the subsidies available
or not i think it does i think
that's fine because i don't have that
yeah that's fine i think it would and
there's up to anybody reading that to
make it what they want so i leave it to
the you know i beauties
and motion is in
the position of the listener would you
be happy to be involved in the
wording of the letter because i'd like
to put in there about it being missed
opportunity yes yeah yeah okay you can
add that in the letter as well
okay we'll keep it simple and i i go
back to the
proposal i would make and i will call
for a sector okay i'm settling that
revoked everyone's favor
anyone against
any abstentions
and i was thinking as well in terms of
council was brought up about planning
and the local plan review
whether the committee should put forward
a recommendation
about the importance of building nature
into developments and highlight that as
part of our local plan review
can you do that without legislation
alone
[Music]
um
i mean i suppose what you could do is uh
impress on the joint committee the
importance of the devon
nature recovery plan
in policymaking yeah i mean and and you
know it's it's over to that committee to
consider that then and obviously it's
going to be considered part of the plan
making process but you know if you
wanted to make that recommendation just
to impress the importance of the
nature recovery plan as part of which
community
the joint planning policy committee will
be the committee that makes decisions on
your new local plan certainly it's not
going to hurt to
insert that given something you think
around yeah okay i would propose that is
there a second
cancellation
in favor
um against
the extensions
thank you and would anyone else like to
raise any
points
can i just ask
one more thing
yeah what what would you
want from us
from councils i mean if there are those
types of proposals are they beneficial
to what you believe in and the hope of
the future and everything or would you
be asking councils to do other things
yeah gosh
so it's a great question i think i think
no no it's a really good question i
think wherever
you have influence and obviously the one
that i'm most aware of is
i think that's where you have the
ability to build some of the stuff in so
the point just raised by the council of
the other cancer was about building
nature into developments i think is
really critical there are obviously
there are mechanisms there already like
a biodiversity net gain
not used as well as they could be
um but i think to i think we can have um
you know
developments of a high quality high
ecological standard as well as having
that you know things like stable air and
drainage schemes and green space there
as well high quality about screen space
it makes a huge difference um and that's
that i think is probably the single
greatest thing that the local authority
can do but then also there's you know
the speeding constructively into all the
the county-based
systems i call an influence like the
carbon plan and other things and
protected landscapes because
where the best
results are
a fact they're always where people are
working together constructively towards
accommodation
yeah thank you
just one last thing i've got written
down about your 25 farm advisors with
the wildlife track why blood trust how
do people access them and just
[Music]
so we've got some through up through the
upstream thinking project which you
might have heard of so that's funded
through southwest water and ourselves
the west country of this trust and over
a cornwall
our sister organization department of
commonwealth trust we all have film
advisors
but they weren't particularly catchments
so here we have them working with the
tamar
we used to have them working on the tour
of torridge but unfortunately southwest
water don't fund us do that anymore
because there isn't a sewage water
treatment works
because they need to justify that in
terms of purifying water downstream but
we do have them working on the tamar
and almost all other
catchments and the other scheme is
something called and this is much more
focused and torrid is called northern
devil natural solutions and that is
funded largely through the environment
agency and
that's really about trying to find the
best places
to um
to manage land in order to benefit the
water resource so it might be slowing
the flow reducing flood peaks um
reducing soil erosion increasing water
quality and we do a lot of work around
the storage on that so the way to access
them um is to give them a call but
actually our guys are um i use that in
the unisex sense of the word
so our people
are
contacting farmers proactively all the
time saying can we come around do a
survey and give you a bit of advice
sometimes they say no but most of the
time they say yes
and you know the mechanism we usually
use is good on stewardship and
whatever's going to replace it local age
recovery scheme whenever we hear the
details of that
so yes okay that's how it works
but the check is 25 now
it seems to change everything it's more
than 20.
it's on youtube
good quality wildlife um i live in a
very rural area
and i went to stay with my son in
stafford the other day and i saw more
wildlife in stafford than i did in my
lovely rural position i saw six foxes
three badgers
[Music]
that were following um the rubbish being
put out
around the various states of stafford
town and apparently these animals now
have learned where the rounds are
because they move from one part of
stafford one night to the next part of
the next night they're running
their way
i know we've got a wonderful league in
our racing recycling here so i'm not
commenting about
um
would you encourage
definitely encourage wildlife in various
ways to come back by various means
because it's very evident
that wildlife responds to positive
strokes and what steps would you
recommend i notice you've got a badger
up there on your and there's a history
between tb and badgers and all the rest
of it which you're aware of i'm aware of
um what would you comment be about
actually positively
encouraging wolves back into
the
area what will we i mean you're talking
to the right writer not necessarily
about wolves but you talk to the right
organization in terms of reproducing
species because of course you've met in
england on the venus and
was full of bits and pieces which were
largely collected from rivers and devon
and including our weaver enclosures so
so there we are um so we're very
interested in bringing stuff back we're
looking at other species as well
we're not actually looking at the wolf
um the reason we're not looking at the
wolf is first of all i don't think the
public is quite ready for it yet
second is i don't think um devon would
be the obvious place to do it because
you actually need a population of about
150 animals right
to sustain for the blood power yeah we
have thought about it and then even
dining was not big enough for that so i
think you know i wouldn't say notables
um indefinitely but i don't think i
don't probably not in my life
because up on um
um there was um the release of some wild
war there was an actual guy there that
you spawned
and they were released into the wild so
it's quite interesting in fact that's
not on a small area yeah of an export so
people
do re-establish themselves after a while
right
came down to step and they've done the
asian first deemed
hundreds of men
um and you know they're controversial um
ecologically they probably have a good
impact although some people think that
they could make quality
but they're yes yes
you know all these animals are
controversial i mean they're one of them
probably they've been wiped out mostly
because they were controversial at some
point i mean pine martens and other
species wildcat the last would you
believe in the last but we think of
wildcats as being scottish
but
they're not well suited to be honest in
the highlands of scotland it's just
where they haven't been shot out but the
last place in england they were found
was on the edge of that small just two
levels
even if it might just be bacteria that
can live pretty much anywhere so you
change the environment something else
will benefit you know rooks
and and rats are very numerous now they
haven't always been and obviously
sparrows were very numerous when we all
had horse straw carts and people used to
spill the grain that was used for
feeding their horses everywhere and uh
asparagus built up and understand um and
you know there's hope as long as we
don't lose things completely always hope
they will come back so i think it's all
about how you manage that
and speak you know and even accept
something like beavers you know
the populations will grow at some point
they will need managing if there isn't
something to leave there and suddenly
that then then at some point they will
be managing but that's the reality of
the landscape we're in we've got
there are lots of lots of easy wins
there's lots of low hanging fruit for
nature out there we should we should
grab it
thank you thank you
so you're not making any recommendations
thank you
[Music]
don't think i need to read them
sorry
thank you
thank you
sorry
yes
[Music]
[Music]
do you want me to read that now should i
read
bureau piece it's 12 pounds i think it's
fifty thousand dollars it should read
um
oh it's got twelve zero
[Music]
what you've done counselor is you fund
them 38 000 pounds a year as a standing
ground last year you made a one-off
twelve thousand pounds there's a zero
[Music]
with those two amendments if you're
happy with the chair yeah very happy and
completely agree councillor newton um
[Music]
and that's really good that we should
recognize that
um do we need to vote on that
so we've already got
[Music]
already organized for 20th of july
linked centers and mental health service
provision
and that's being confirmed
yeah she's requested and she's been um
she's been in contact with them to offer
the date to them
okay
so
14th of september
there's a few suggestions underneath
um
in terms of presentations you've just
been in one focus i think that's worked
quite well because previously
so should we look at filling a few more
if it's possible yeah it can be a
presentation but some sort of
um
is if you're here inspite the clinical
commission indeed yeah i can try and
i'll find out who that is
so it was only yesterday i've seen
people on social media saying that they
can't get their children
yeah
it's a real problem i don't know how we
can tackle it as a council that's the
thing but we can raise the
concern over
exactly there september should we put
their 14th of september
getting great okay what about 26th of
october
i'd be quite keen to hear from burton
art gallery because they've been doing
little things and we haven't had from
them
that's halfway through the year so it's
a it's just a halfway review of 30 years
one
yeah we've got the community safety
partnership that happens
yeah on in the year that's okay because
that's the statutory portion of the uh
group should we put that for 26th of
october then the csp yeah yeah and maybe
7th of december
gallery
suggestions and then when councilor
manley's backing
did you feel you want to raise them
about cap
oh yeah
perhaps depends and you have um concern
about the citizens yeah just to raise um
there was report
to all members from stacy dory last week
i'm the link member with his advice it
was a good report and they did a lot of
good work um um in regards to the
situation and there's a good report
there um about nominees benefits it's um
working with a single unit which i've
taught before that people facing illness
and the people facing illness that have
a hard job particularly for a working
age
um but what i'm getting back
is a situation of people failing to be
able to contact the cap
and um
i i did email stacey and i tried to
speak to vicky a pixelated six i just
wondered if anybody has had any other
reactions or any difficulties in
contacting
and i just want a little bit more focus
towards means tested benefits
i was shocked i have to say i was
shocked
that this universal help with our
electric bills and not
focus on those that need it most um in
last week's government announcements and
i really would like to focus if i could
on um your
mean tested benefits and that means
pension credit for those who were a
pensionable age and universal credit
usually for those of uh working age
and i would like a report if i could and
i would like to report to include
something about availability
of the service to particularly those who
are
electronically disadvantaged because i
think there is a real problem there with
people who don't know how to use
electronic communications
i was going to say because when they
came and spoke to us they said the best
way to contact them is through facebook
but obviously if you haven't got that
access
sure i mean if we're bringing a report
back to the next meeting to talk about
the funding the funding was specifically
designed to improve their
interaction with the public most of need
at this time of crisis i don't see any
reason why we couldn't ask those
questions of vicky for inclusion within
the report
and then
put it into the next report for the next
committee i mean it might just be a
paragraph response from vicki but it
would be something
excellent we can speak as well because i
think the recommendation coming out the
last time they came was for chris fuller
to make contact offering trying to work
that part time or something and i know
he made content
and in the last
news sector and only mentioned
offices at torrington and finisher and
it's not universal across toronto i
don't want to be too pacific but there
was a there's a gap across the wider
rural area
if you didn't capture what kind of
cancer pennington wanted us to ask vicki
the question yes yes
thank you yes thank you
firstly
i'll tell you what else do i have to do
can i just double check something i'm
assuming anything about the play
strategy would be in would be in
internal wouldn't it
it's just the play strategy was
mentioned in the review joey mentioned
in the review so
if we wanted to
sort of look at that halfway through the
year or something that would be an
internal
i think it is
well
it's very difficult actually i'm not
sure there's a qbr measure in internal
that would track the delivery strategy
i don't i can't recall at qbr
and we had adrian
doesn't mean i mean i i don't think
there's any problem with adrian coming
back and giving you
at some point
because it's not actually on there is it
and i think that would be
um i mean i i said leave it if you want
until joe's back but certainly i would
if it's not going to be on internal i
would like it on external
i was wondering if because we've got
down here richard hayes parks grand
maintenance whether that could be
richard pace and adrian angry because
they're kind of working together i don't
know
yeah
because they go hand in hand now that
we've got it back in hands
don't know when we would put that in the
cycle well i know six months of school
excuse me six months ago would be a good
time so after after six months of uh uh
us bringing the service back in house i
think
uh richard um
he's getting the handle on it already i
know but
he's learning something new every day so
it'll probably be good to wait six
months and then he can tell you how it's
before should we put that in then
provisioning
february
yep
yep councilman
i'm i'm just a bit um
[Music]
um
i can't understand why
you think the close strategy
um and richard haste and the services
he's providing
are external matters they're internal
services i know they've always come to
this committee for some reason i don't
know why the grounds maintenance was an
external contract
i don't think naturally there's going to
be an enquiry
from
internal into the play strategy delivery
because there's no formal reporting
mechanism within the qbr for them to
interrogate on that
so i guess you're the committee here
that proposed that strategy and you're
just interested to see how it's
progressing in terms of grant
maintenance on reflection i completely
agree with you on that point i think
that's arguing
can i come back again chair yeah i'm
glad
sean has understood my message but with
referring to the play strategies and
saying there isn't anything in the qbr
process
the issue for me is that we review
our strategic plans
and that is um
something that is contained within the
qbi
so therefore the play strategy falls
part of that and it's not i'm trying to
take something away from this committee
but i think it's important it's heard in
the context it should be yeah i think
you're right i don't i we all left each
other like yeah we do agree with that
you think it's something that wants to
be taken up with the chair of the
international yes that's a
recommendation from here too
yes that we need to we need to have that
under review
it had been dealt with here when it was
in its infancy but now we recognize it's
an important part to be reviewed under
attorney
yeah i'm
point of view here because we did so
much work on the pay strategy prior to
the um um last
full time so i don't know three years
ago then uh looking at the play strategy
put it there's recommendations in place
and i think it was me that made a call
in to bring one of the issues about
funding to full council so there is a
real role for for external here to look
at the social bound
of of some of our institutions i think
internals going down the line of of
looking at the cost of everything and
the value of nothing and and we have to
have a balance here um and i think that
what external do so well is to look at
the wider social values and today's been
a classic example because we look at the
wider issues of the use of our countries
now and our play parts their open spaces
and this is social value and i think
it's external for our
partners here and the people and i think
it's really fundamental that this
committee keep a home that they can ask
any officer providing services that come
to our meeting if it's so much of the
council and i think the playing park
strategy is fundamental to being part of
the forward plan if we wanted
shall we keep that as
say remove your browns maintenance and
just keep it as player is coming in
february what about recommendations to
internal that we'd like it well i report
we don't remove the very maintenance
external
issues that affect the tourist
um
yeah maybe internal but the effects the
effects that it has on
everybody else is an external thing and
i think you should be able to ask
questions
on that
you can't tell you can do it through
internal administrators
if they have it brought to them
[Music]
building chair my standby i think i
might have had to step in there
i'm sure yeah
so i i mean from a process point of view
i think i agree entirely that the branch
maintenance is an entirely internal
matter and that the questions around
social value could be put to the
internal committee
because actually it doesn't matter which
committee asks the questions um as long
as you get the answers in terms of the
play i think there is a dimension of it
that is related to external in the
community engagement bit that was done
so perhaps if you specifically focused
on that last adrian to produce your
report not necessarily about how much
we've spent on improving our own play
areas but how much work we've done with
our communities to improve their lives
which is another strategic objective
there's a fundamental question here
scrutiny works on this council
we seem not
to be listened to everyone external when
we call things in and then we're getting
sidelined if we vote against this
proposal moving forward we as a
committee have a choice if we want to
bring point things forward and we must
scrutinize the decision making because
it does affect external people outside
our internal our parish partners and all
the rest and i would go back to my
proposal that we should be able to
invite the very maintenance people here
and i stand by that proposal
um
do you have a second
second
i think
well
it can be decided on that at a later
date anyway because it wasn't for the
next meeting was it it was for
february
you were in the chair
you don't know
but
i disagreed but
[Music]
do we need to vote
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]